uh we could see white's rook the the  front rook that is attacked right now by  black's bishop by blackstroke  it i mean it has no safe squares it  could just go and exchange itself off  and all the rooks will just disappear  i'm trying to look for other options  reports looking for other options but i  can't see a way to keep all the rooks on  the board and giri's trying to force the  exchange of the rooks because he's  gambiting on the fact that  the more pieces that disappear will  favor his bishop pair black's two  bishops  clearly superior to white's knights at  the moment so  yeah we will see a transition  transformation into a proper end game  now  and who will that favor i think black  it has to be black